Every night, when I was a kid, my family would sit down to dinner together. And every night, as best as I can remember, when the meal was done, my mom would take the ice from her glass, tip it back into her mouth, and chew on it loudly. And every night, all of us would ask her, "Please don't crunch the ice. Please never, ever, ever do that again." And every night, she would ignore this request.
我小时候，每天晚上全家人都会坐在一起吃晚饭。我记得每晚吃完饭，妈妈都会把杯子里的冰块倒进嘴里，大声嚼着。每天晚上我们都会求她：“求你别嚼冰块了，求你千万别再这样了。”可每晚，她都对我们的请求置之不理。
And in retrospect, I have to say, I got to hand it to my mom. She is not somebody to be pushed around. This is just who she is. She is willful. She gets her way. It's something to be admired.
回想起来，我不得不说，我真佩服我妈。她可不是那种任人摆布的人。她就是这样的人，很有主见，总能如愿以偿。这一点确实值得钦佩。
And of course, this story happened at the dinner table. The dinner table is the stage for so many family dramas. Today on our program, we bring you three stories about families at mealtime. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
当然，这个故事发生在餐桌上。餐桌是上演许多家庭剧的舞台。今天我们的节目为大家带来三个关于家庭用餐的故事。这里是 WBEZ 芝加哥和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today's program, You Gonna Eat That? Three families, three stories, in three acts. Act one, Breakfast, a story of eating and not eating, and what you learn when you view the world through the prism of a single meal. Act two, Lunch, we hear a father's lament about sippy cups, chewing with your mouth closed, and why it is not good to apply tape to the cat. Act three, Dinner. We have a story from Dave Eggers about what family dinner's like when the parents are suddenly gone, and the kids are left to run things themselves. Stay with us.
今天的节目主题是《你打算吃那个吗？》。三个家庭，三个故事，分三幕呈现。第一幕，“早餐”，一个关于进食与拒食的故事，以及当你通过单次用餐的棱镜观察世界时所学到的东西。第二幕，“午餐”，我们来听一位父亲关于吸管杯、闭嘴咀嚼的抱怨，以及为什么不该往猫身上贴胶带。第三幕，“晚餐”。我们将讲述戴夫·埃格斯的故事，关于当父母突然离去，孩子们只能自己当家作主时，家庭晚餐是什么样子。请继续收听。
Act One, Breakfast. In every family, there are the family legends that everyone in the family repeats over and over. And then there are the stories that are suppressed, disappeared with a kind of Stalinist thoroughness. This next story falls more into that second camp than the first. It lay dormant for a long time before Annie Cheney decided to tell it here. It was produced by Jay Allison.
第一幕，早餐。每个家庭都有家族传说，家里人会一遍又一遍地讲述。也有一些故事被压制，以斯大林式的彻底手段消失殆尽。接下来这个故事更属于后者。它在被安妮·切尼讲述出来之前，已经沉寂了很久。本节目的制作人是杰·艾利森。
This morning for breakfast, I had a toasted everything bagel with eggs and cheese and a cup of Earl Gray tea with--
今天早餐我吃了全麦百吉饼配蛋和奶酪，还喝了一杯伯爵茶，配上——
A reporter where I used to work taught me to ask people what they had for breakfast at the beginning of an interview. He said it was a good way to set your recording levels.
我以前工作时的一位记者教我，在采访开始时问受访者早餐吃了什么。他说这是调整录音电平的好方法。
In 1996, Seattle police officers faced a tense situation when they were called out--
1996年，西雅图警方在接到报警后，面临着紧张的局面——
That's me on the radio in Seattle. I was a reporter for a public station. They didn't pay me or anything. I was just a volunteer. But I was still a reporter. I had a microphone and a tape recorder, and I went to press conferences.
那是电台里的我，在西雅图。我当时是一家公共电台的记者。他们不付我工资，我只是个志愿者。但我还是个记者，我有麦克风和录音机，还会去参加新闻发布会。
--department, they flooded it with tear gas.
——部门，他们向里面投放了催泪瓦斯。
I wasn't very good at it. I couldn't stand being told what to say, and I was too cowardly to figure out the truth for myself.
我干得并不好。我受不了别人告诉我要说什么，而且我太胆小，不敢自己去挖掘真相。
--came out firing his gun, and officers retaliated, shooting him nine times.
——出来时开了枪，警员们进行了回击，向他开了九枪。
A lot of times, the most revealing response I got from people was what they had for breakfast. And it was the most interesting to me.
很多时候，我从受访者那里得到的最具启发性的回答就是他们早餐吃了什么。这对我也最有趣。
--program is working. I'm Annie Cheney for KUOW, 94.9, public radio.
——节目运行正常。我是 KUOW 94.9 频道的安妮·切尼，公共广播电台。
So I decided to follow my instincts and tell a story about breakfast. I got on a plane to New York, and I looked up my old friend, Vivian.
所以我决定追随直觉，讲一个关于早餐的故事。我飞往纽约，找我的老朋友维维安。
OK, so tell me what you had for breakfast.
好了，告诉我你早餐吃了什么。
Oh my god, you don't really want to know. Eight ounces of nonfat, plain Stonyfield yogurt, mixed with one whole 35-calorie, non-sodium rice cake, mixed with a five-ounce cup of Kashi cereal, mixed with a half an ounce, one of those little boxes, of raisins, mixed with a tablespoon of flaxseed powder--
天哪，你肯定不想知道。8盎司脱脂原味 Stonyfield 酸奶，混入一个35卡路里的无钠米饼，混入一杯5盎司的 Kashi 麦片，混入半盎司（那种小盒子装的）葡萄干，混入一汤匙亚麻籽粉——
Vivian is a friend from my past. I met her when I was 15. She was 36. And sometimes, I think she saved my life.
维维安是我过去的朋友。我15岁时认识她，她那时36岁。有时我觉得她救了我的命。
A cup of black coffee, and guilt.
一杯黑咖啡，还有内疚感。
When she agreed to meet me, I didn't know what to expect. I hadn't seen her in 10 years. And I didn't know if I'd hug her and just feel bones, or if she'd be strong, the way I remember her. It turns out she's had a hard time. She didn't get better. And she almost died.
当她同意和我见面时，我不知道会发生什么。我有10年没见她了。我不知道见到她时，我是会抱住她只感受到骨头，还是她会像我记忆中那样强壮。结果是，她过得很艰难。她没有好转，而且差点死掉。
When I was going down towards 60, I would crawl out of bed, out of the futon. I'd be lying there having a panic attack that I was having heart palpitations. And it was, it was hard to breathe.
当我的体重降到60磅左右时，我会从床上爬出来，从日式床垫上爬出来。我会躺在那儿，因为心悸而惊恐发作。那种感觉……呼吸很困难。
And I got to get some food. And I thought about the food I'd get. And I was alone in the house.
我得吃点东西。我琢磨着要吃什么，当时我一个人在家。
And I would crawl to the kitchen. I'm getting dizzy even thinking about now. And I'd crawl up to the fridge, and I'd open it up. And I'd be on my knees. And I'd take out a spoon. And I'd open a yogurt.
我会爬向厨房。现在想到这我都会头晕。我爬到冰箱前，打开它。我跪在地上，拿出一把勺子，打开一盒酸奶。
And I'd take a spoonful. And I could feel it go down and really feel it go down my chest, the coolness of it, like it was flip-flopping every rib down and dripping off my ribs into my stomach. And suddenly, one heaping teaspoon, and I would got, "Wow, that was just what I needed." And I'd get standing back on my feet, and I'd go, "I'm fine."
我舀了一勺。我能感觉到它顺着喉咙下去，真的能感觉到它顺着胸口流下，那种凉意就像流过每一根肋骨，最后滴进胃里。突然间，吃下一满勺，我会说：“哇，这就是我需要的。”然后我站起来，说：“我没事了。”
I met Vivian when I was anorectic. We shared a room in a hospital where there were other anorectics. I'd lost my period then, and my breasts. My bones stuck out, and I wanted to die. Vivian pulled me out of that. She convinced me by example to get better. And so I did. But sitting here, looking at her now, I realized that she never planned on getting better.
我认识维维安时，正患有厌食症。我们在医院共用一个房间，那里还有其他厌食症患者。当时我停经了，胸部也没了。我的骨头凸出来，我想死。维维安拉了我一把。她用自己的经历说服我好起来。于是我真的好起来了。但现在坐在这里看着她，我意识到她从未打算好起来。
They had to take out most of my back top teeth because they were deteriorating and there was bone loss. It was the malnutrition that did that. So they took them out. And I thought, "This is really great," because now my cheeks would sink in the back, like the models.
他们不得不拔掉了我大部分上后牙，因为它们已经损坏且伴有骨质流失。是营养不良造成的。所以拔掉了。我觉得“这真好”，因为现在我的脸颊后面会凹陷下去，像模特一样。
You did not.
你才没有呢。
I did. Oh, absolutely. And then, he said he'd have to make me a removable denture. So I said to him, when you make it, make it so that the back of it slants in, so that my cheekbones-- my face will be as sunken as it can be.
我有。噢，绝对有。然后医生说必须给我做一副活动假牙。所以我对他说，做的时候，把它后面做成倾斜的，这样我的颧骨……我的脸就会凹陷得尽可能厉害。
When was this?
这是什么时候的事？
Well, I've had it maybe for a year and a half. I don't know. Or less.
嗯，大概做了一年半吧。我不知道。或者更短。
Would you still say that today?
你今天还会这么说吗？
Probably.
可能会。
Vivian's wrist bones could easily fit in a child's fist. She wears a little T-shirt, and you can see the way her stomach sticks out, hard as bone, as if someone had inflated her like a balloon. I still think she's beautiful because I hold on to the way she was when I first met her. But listening to her talk scares me. It makes me worry that change is impossible, and that we're stuck with who we are.
维维安的手腕骨完全能塞进小孩子的拳头里。她穿着一件小T恤，你能看到她的肚子凸出来，硬得像骨头，好像被人吹成了一个气球。我依然觉得她很美，因为我固守着初次见她时的印象。但听她这么说让我感到害怕。这让我担心改变是不可能的，我们注定只能是现在的自己。
Anorectics are good at PR. They can make you believe anything. I should know. My whole family's good at Public Relations. My father was even a PR man. They still issue press releases for my illness. My father says, "You made us a better family." My mother says, "It showed how sensitive and artistic you are." My brother says, "It was a testament to your strength that you got better." But I don't know how it turned out, or if it's over, or if any of the things they are true.
厌食症患者很擅长公关。她们能让你相信任何事。这一点我很清楚。我们全家都很擅长公关。我父亲甚至就是个公关人员。他们至今还在为我的疾病发新闻稿。我父亲说：“你让我们成为了一个更好的家庭。”我母亲说：“这显示了你有多敏感和艺术化。”我哥哥说：“你能好起来是对你坚强毅力的证明。”但我不知道最后的结果如何，不知道这一切是否结束，也不知道他们说的那些是否属实。
I had half a croissant, toasted, with peach jam, Dad's peach jam that he makes, the non-cook method.
我吃了半个烤牛角包，配上桃子果酱，是我爸自己做的桃子果酱，不用煮的那种方法。
That's my mother. Her recording levels are too hot. She's distorting.
那就是我妈妈。她的录音电平太高了，声音失真了。
Well, I buy these calendars for every year, and they show a month at a time on a page. And I've saved them back to the '60s. It's very interesting. I can see in here when Mrs. Boyle is picking you up from school and who's coming to play, and dentist appointments.
我每年都会买这种挂历，一页显示一个月。我从60年代起就一直留着它们。很有意思。我能从里面看到博伊尔太太什么时候接你放学，谁来家里玩，还有牙医预约时间。
As a reporter, I was taught to get the hard facts first. So I start with a written record.
作为记者，我被教导先掌握确凿的事实。所以我从书面记录开始。
And I see here that all I have on the day that you went in the hospital is that we had a dinner with the Anthonys. And I also had an appointment at your high school, which I gather I didn't keep. But I did put a red star on there, which meant that was the date that you went in the hospital.
我看到你住院那天我唯一记录的就是我们要和安东尼一家吃晚饭。我还和你高中约了面谈，我想我没去成。但我画了一个红星，那代表你住院的日子。
There's no written record after all, just a red star and a calendar full of details. It's as though that day never happened.
事实证明根本没有文字记录，只有一个红星和一本写满细节的日历。就好像那天从未发生过一样。
I think it was sort of a denial. I just couldn't believe it.
我想那是一种否认。我简直不敢相信。
Even though it's not on the calendar, it turns out she remembers everything from that day.
尽管日历上没写，但结果是她记得那天发生的一切。
Well, it was the middle of January. It was bitterly cold. I think there was something like an ice storm. There had been terrible ice.
嗯，那是1月中旬。天气极冷。我想当时好像有一场冰暴。结了很可怕的冰。
There were no cabs, and we had this very early morning appointment. You refused to put on enough clothing to confront that kind of cold. And so that was horrible enough as it was. And you had no socks, as I recall.
没有出租车，而我们有一个很早的预约。你拒绝穿足够的衣服来抵御那样的寒冷。那已经够可怕了。我记得你连袜子都没穿。
So we had the terrible difficulty that those situations entailed of struggling with you, trying to convince you, and finally deciding we just had to get out of there. And so I think I took some extra things with me, just in case we could persuade you to put them on. And we went outside.
所以在那类情况下，我们要费劲地和你争执，试图说服你，最后决定必须得出发。我想我带了一些额外的衣服，以防能说服你穿上。我们走出了门。
And people were rushing off to offices, and parents were taking their children to school. And we couldn't get a cab anywhere. So we finally went down to the corner and got on the crosstown bus. I think all three of us were standing up in the bus, holding on. It was very crowded. All three of us were standing up, but we were not standing together.
人们匆匆赶去办公室，家长们送孩子去学校。我们在任何地方都叫不到车。最后我们走到街角，上了跨城巴士。我想我们三个人都站在巴士上，抓着扶手。车里很挤。我们三个都站着，但并不站在一起。
But now that I think about it, it was remarkable that you actually stayed with us. In the past, you'd walk away. You'd leave. You wouldn't come.
但现在想起来，你居然能跟我们在一起真的很了不起。过去你肯定会走开。你会离开。你才不会来呢。
We got off the bus, and I remember somehow walking those last six blocks. And it was so bitter. And we tried to cross the street, and it was a sheet of ice.
我们下了车，我记得我们不知怎么走完了最后六个街区。天气太冷了。我们要过马路时，路面就像冰面一样。
And Dad was slipping, and you were, I think, slipping. And it was extreme discomfort and despair. And of course, the situation was the same way.
你爸爸在滑倒，我想你也滑倒了。那是一种极度的不适和绝望。当然，当时的状况也是如此。
My mother's story fits my memory of that whole period, me in the middle of my two parents, slipping in my leopard skin high heel shoes. My mother doesn't mention what got us there, though. In fact, no matter how hard I try to remind her, she won't remember.
我母亲的故事符合我对那段时期的记忆：我夹在父母中间，穿着豹纹高跟鞋滑倒。但我母亲没提到是什么原因导致我们去那儿。事实上，无论我怎么努力提醒她，她都不愿记得。
Do you remember when I took all those pills?
你还记得我吃下那些药的时候吗？
Was that before you went in the hospital? Oh yes, I do remember that, but not too clearly. I remember you were in your room, and you were in your bed. And you were-- what had happened? What kind of pills were they that you took?
那是你住院之前吗？噢，是的，我记得，但不那么清晰了。我记得你在房间里，躺在床上。然后——发生了什么？你吃的是什么药？
They were antihistamines.
是抗组胺药。
And what was that supposed to do for you?
那本来是想给你起到什么作用？
Sleep forever.
永远睡去。
Forever? Oh my god. I guess I must have focused on that. But that's just a terrible memory. Was that in the fall? and what happened? Did you vomit them, and then somehow you woke up? Or did you not take enough, or what? We didn't have to get any emergency service.
永远？天哪。我想我当时一定只关注了那个。但那真是个可怕的记忆。那是在秋天吗？发生了什么？你把它们吐出来了，然后不知怎么就醒了？还是你没吃够，或者什么？我们当时没有叫救护车。
I didn't take enough.
我没吃够。
Oh, that was wonderful.
噢，那太好了。
Now, just like then, sometimes the most obvious things go unrecognized.
现在，就像那时候一样，最明显的事情有时反而被忽视了。
I almost was wishing that this wasn't happening in what I otherwise thought was a really ideal life. I though, "Ah, everything is so wonderful now. It's so much fun, and I'm enjoying everything. I can't believe this. How could this be happening when everything is going so well?"
我当时几乎是在祈祷这不要发生在被我视为理想生活的一切中。我想，“啊，现在一切都太美好了。太有趣了，我很享受这一切。我不敢相信。当一切都这么顺利时，怎么会发生这种事？”
Starvation gets people's attention when nothing else will. Anorectics know that. I knew that.
当别的方法都不奏效时，饥饿能引起人们的注意。厌食症患者知道这一点。我知道这一点。
I learned it when I was 14. I, at one time, could play all of the movements, which were four movements, I think. And the reason why I played the piece in the first place was that I used to listen to the version that Horowitz played. When I was sick, I would play it over and over and over again in the living room on my father phonograph.
我在14岁时就学会了。我曾经能弹奏所有的乐章，我想是四个乐章。我最初弹这首曲子的原因是我常听霍洛维茨的版本。生病时，我会在客厅的父亲的唱片机上一遍又一遍地播放。
And I remember sitting in this big chair by the window. And I would drink this tea that I always drank when I was sick, because I was freezing all the time. And I would eat a carrot because carrots are the vegetables that are the lowest in calories. And then I would eat the carrot like a corncob because carrots have many layers. So you nibble around the outside level, and then you come to another carrot inside.
我记得我坐在窗边那张大椅子里。我会喝那种我生病时总喝的茶，因为我一直觉得很冷。我会吃胡萝卜，因为胡萝卜是热量最低的蔬菜。我会像啃玉米棒一样吃胡萝卜，因为胡萝卜有很多层。所以你先啃掉最外层，然后里面还有另一层胡萝卜。
At 5:00 in the morning, when it was still dark, the night nurse would come by to check on us. I can remember the sound of her keys clanging. She had a face like an owl and short dark hair that was always a little bit greasy. At night, she gave out medications and extra Tylenol for anyone who couldn't sleep. We would line up like fluttering, bony birds, hunched over in hospital gowns, waiting patiently for a dose of peace.
凌晨5点，天还黑着，夜班护士会过来查房。我记得她钥匙碰撞的声音。她长着一张猫头鹰脸，短短的深色头发总是有点油腻。晚上，她会给那些睡不着的人发药和额外的泰诺。我们像一群颤抖的、瘦骨嶙峋的鸟，穿着医院的病号服蜷缩着，耐心地等待这一剂安宁。
Then it was snack time, a can or two of chocolate Sustacal for the skinniest and least compliant of us. 10:30, to bed. There's nothing worse when you're sick than to have to lie down with a full stomach. I can remember shaking my legs under the covers, flexing my feet, tightening every muscle to burn up my snack.
然后是点心时间，一两罐巧克力营养补充液，给那些最瘦、最不听话的人。10点半睡觉。生病时最糟糕的事莫过于顶着饱胀的肚子躺下。我记得我在被子里晃动双腿，绷紧脚尖，收缩每一块肌肉来消耗掉那点点心。
When I first moved in, I shared a room with a tall, blonde flight attendant. She was also a nurse. Before she moved into the anorectic ward, she took turns at both jobs, a 12-hour shift at the hospital, and then off on a plane somewhere. She worked 24 hours a day, she said, just to wear herself out. She was the one who taught me how to do aerobics in the closet. We would get up at 5:00 together, turn on our radio just barely enough to hear it, and then we'd jump up and down in our socks.
刚搬进去时，我和一位高挑的金发空姐共用一个房间。她也是一名护士。搬进厌食症病房前，她身兼两职，在医院上12小时班，然后飞往某地。她说她一天工作24小时，只是为了让自己筋疲力尽。是她教我在衣柜里做有氧运动。我们一起在5点起床，把收音机音量调到刚好能听见，然后穿着袜子上下跳动。
At 7:00, the day nurse arrived and herded us into the bathroom, where we were supposed to get rid of as much as possible before we got weighed. I remember Vivian standing at the sink, drinking cup after cup of water to throw off the scales and convince the doctor she was eating. But this was in the beginning, when I still wanted to starve and expected everyone else to want to, too.
7点钟，日班护士来了，把我们赶进浴室，要求我们在称重前尽可能排出体内的东西。我记得维维安站在水槽边，一杯接一杯地喝水，想干扰秤的读数，让医生相信她在进食。但这还是刚开始的时候，当时我仍然想饿死自己，并期待别人也这么想。
Weigh-in was sometime after the bathroom visit. We'd go down to the room that had a scale and line up outside, one person at a time only. I'd stand with my back to the scale because I didn't want to watch the numbers. Afterwards, I'd ask how much.
称重在浴室之后，我们下楼到那个有秤的房间，在外面排队，一次只能进一个人。我背对着秤站着，因为我不想看数字。结束后，我会问是多少。
There was always some commotion at weigh-in. Someone would start wailing or shaking or screaming. They didn't want to get on the scale. They didn't want to eat. Go to hell.
称重时总会有些骚乱。有人会开始嚎哭、发抖或尖叫。她们不想站到秤上，她们不想吃东西。去死吧。
There we all were, in a frenzy about our bodies and about facing the truth of the scale. Women with children and husbands, young girls and 20-somethings who looked, at times, 80, and at times, like infants. And then, it was time for breakfast.
我们就那样站在那儿，为我们的身体、为面对秤上真相的恐惧而发狂。有带着孩子和丈夫的妇女，有看起来时而80岁、时而像婴儿的年轻女孩和二十几岁的人。然后，到了早餐时间。
Well, I had a blueberry muffin, fresh mint tea, fresh raspberries, fresh black raspberries, and a half a bagel and strawberry jam.
嗯，我吃了一个蓝莓松饼，新鲜薄荷茶，新鲜树莓，新鲜黑树莓，还有半个百吉饼和草莓酱。
That's my father in a lounge chair in his favorite spot.
那是我父亲在他最喜欢的躺椅上。
We're in historic Columbia County, in the back yard of our home, in what we call "the oasis," looking out over the pool, with a huge tree over our head, rock wall around, and tables and chairs here, so we could eat out here if we ever want to.
我们在历史悠久的哥伦比亚县，我们家后院，也就是我们称之为“绿洲”的地方，俯瞰着泳池，头顶有一棵大树，周围是石墙，还有桌椅，想在外面吃的时候就可以在这吃。
The thing you have to understand about my father is that he grew up poor, and then he got rich. There are times he remembers when he didn't have enough to eat. Sometimes, he even stole food for his dinner. Now, he's known for his brilliant gourmet cooking.
关于我父亲，你必须了解的是，他家境贫寒，后来发了家。有时他会想起自己吃不饱的时候。甚至有时为了晚饭不得不去偷食物。现在，他以精湛的美食烹饪而闻名。
The thing that, of course, absolutely destroyed me, came close to destroying me, was when you suddenly decided you weren't going to eat. And I couldn't believe that I'd worked all that time and tried to provide food and undergone a lot of humiliation in work, where somebody's your boss, and you have things you don't like about it, and everything else. You work to bring home money to help everybody have a good living and eat.
最让我痛苦，差点毁灭我的事，是你突然决定不再吃东西。我无法相信我工作了那么久，试图提供食物，在工作中忍受了那么多的屈辱——有个老板，有你不喜欢的东西，还有其他一切。你为了带回钱让大家过上好日子、有饭吃而工作。
When somebody decides not to eat, that really does throw it back in your face. What the hell have I've been living for? I've been trying to help this family and self-sacrificing and a lot of other stuff. And all of the sudden, somebody's trying to kill themselves by not eating. And you ask yourself, did I have anything to do with this?
当有人决定不吃东西时，这真的让我感觉像是甩了我一脸。我到底是为了什么活着？我一直在努力帮助这个家庭，自我牺牲，还有很多别的事。突然之间，有人想要通过不吃东西来寻死。你问自己，这和我有关吗？
Anorexia is embarrassing. It embarrassed my father, humiliated him.
厌食症很尴尬。它让我父亲感到尴尬，让他感到屈辱。
The thing that still strikes me in my memory, the height of the defiance, was we had gone out to dinner at some restaurant along Columbus. And you got angry at dinner, for a reason I didn't fully understand, because you wouldn't eat, and I was trying to get you to eat, because I thought, this girl, if she keeps this up, she's going to starve to death. I suppose she'd also disgrace me by starving herself to death.
至今仍浮现在我记忆中、最叛逆的行为，是我们去哥伦布大道边的一家餐厅吃晚饭。你在晚餐时发火了，原因我没完全弄明白，因为你不吃东西，而我试着让你吃，因为我想，这个女孩如果继续这样，她会饿死的。我想她也会因为饿死而让我丢脸。
And then what? Everyone would just think--
那又怎样？每个人都会觉得——
Well, no. Everybody would say something was wrong in that household. The parents had something wrong with them, because their child starved herself to death. And it must have been terrible, that she'd want to starve herself to death to get out of that family. So anyway, and I felt like I had an obligation to get you to eat. You're supposed to keep your children alive.
嗯，不。每个人都会说那个家庭出了问题。父母一定有问题，因为孩子把自己饿死了。那一定很可怕，她居然想通过饿死自己来逃离那个家。总之，我觉得我有责任让你吃东西。你应该让你的孩子活着。
So I followed you down the block there, behind the museum. And I was saying, "Come back. Come back. You have to eat." And you bit me in the arm. I was trying to take a-- And then this man ran up to you and me. And he turned to you, and he said, "What's going on here? Are you all right?" he said to you. I could see he thought I was an abusive parent.
所以我跟着你走下那个街区，在博物馆后面。我说：“回来，回来。你必须吃东西。”然后你咬了我的胳膊。我试图拿走一个——然后这个男人冲到我们身边。他转向你，说：“怎么了？你还好吗？”他问你。我看得出他以为我是个虐待孩子的父亲。
And he was asking you if he should do anything. It was totally humiliating to have a total stranger say, "Should I be helping you," meaning you, not me, "take this brute away," beating him up or getting him out of here so you won't be abused by this guy. I'll tell you, that was very humiliating.
他问你是否需要帮忙。让一个完全陌生的人说“我需要帮你吗”——指的是你，不是我，“带走这个野蛮人”，或者打他一顿，把他赶走，好让你不被这个家伙虐待，这简直太屈辱了。我告诉你，那真是太屈辱了。
What I wanted by whittling myself down to the core was to get my father to see me more clearly, to realize that I was separate from him, and that he should love me anyway, maybe even because we were different. That's what I wanted then, although I never told him.
我通过把自己削减到极致所想要的是，让我父亲更清楚地看到我，意识到我是一个独立于他的个体，他应该爱我，也许是因为我们不同。我当时想要的就是这个，尽管我从未告诉他。
Today, I had scrambled eggs, toast, raspberries, orange juice, and coffee.
今天，我吃了炒鸡蛋、烤面包、树莓、橙汁和咖啡。
When I got sick, my older brother was away at college. Even though he wasn't around that much, he knew something was wrong with me, even before I started to lose weight. And it bothered him because of what it meant about me and what it could mean for him, and because it wasn't supposed to happen.
我生病时，我哥哥在外地上大学。尽管他不在身边，但在我开始变瘦之前，他就知道我出事了。这让他很困扰，因为这关系到我，可能也关系到他，而且这事本不该发生。
It was a little strange because you don't really understand why it just pops up, like a mushroom on your lawn one day. Suddenly, it's there. And you're like, "Oh. What is this?" But I just didn't understand how we could be so closely related and have such different interpretations of things and experiences of things.
这有点奇怪，因为你真的不明白为什么它会突然冒出来，就像某天你草坪上冒出一朵蘑菇。突然之间，它就在那儿了。你会想，“噢，这是什么？”但我就是不明白我们关系如此亲近，为什么会对事情有如此不同的解读和体验。
So you felt everything was fine?
所以你觉得一切都很好？
Well, I think I didn't want to think that things weren't fine.
嗯，我想我不想认为事情不顺。
What do you mean?
什么意思？
Well, I think there was always an emphasis on being perfect in the family. Everything had to be perfect. I liked that idea. I still feel that way in many ways.
嗯，我觉得家里一直强调要完美。一切都必须完美。我喜欢这个想法。在许多方面，我至今仍有这种感觉。
I get upset when there's evidence to the contrary that I'm perfect, which is often. I don't like to admit that. Maybe you provided evidence that things might not be perfect by the way you were acting. And I was very upset that you were shattering the glass on this nice window, you know?
当有证据表明我不完美（这经常发生）时，我会很难过。我不喜欢承认这一点。也许你通过你的行为提供了事情可能并不完美的证据。而我非常生气你打破了这扇漂亮窗户上的玻璃，你懂吗？
One way our family was perfect, I mean really perfect, was at the breakfast table.
我们家完美的一个方面，我是说真的很完美，就是在早餐桌上。
In our family, there's a lot of dishes. And there's a lot of dishes for different types of courses, and cutlery and silverware. Our table, sometimes I'd look, and there'd be so many plates on the table, you could barely see the table, even for a simple breakfast. So no meal was simple. Everything was very elaborate and formalized and ceremonial, and had a lot of different-- it was very complicated. You could never have a simple breakfast.
我们家的餐具很多。不同类型的菜肴配有不同的盘子，还有餐具和银器。有时我会看我们的餐桌，上面的盘子多到你几乎看不见桌子，哪怕只是简单的早餐。所以没有哪顿饭是简单的。一切都非常繁复、正规、讲究仪式，包含了很多不同的东西——非常复杂。你永远不可能吃顿简单的早餐。
Like a bowl of cereal or something?
比如一碗麦片什么的？
No, no, that could never happen.
不，不，那绝对不可能。
A lot of people like to cut corners and not have a full breakfast. But I've always felt it was nice. It was a pleasant experience. And it's one that stays with one. Four glass plates.
很多人喜欢省事，不吃全套早餐。但我一直觉得那样很好。这是一种愉快的体验。而且它会留在人的记忆里。四个玻璃盘子。
What are those for?
那些是用来干嘛的？
Well, that goes under the fruit, or whatever else somebody might have, poached eggs, or it depends. I suppose the whole basis of it is that I just like it to look nice. And I think gives you a lift, even if you're just passing through, and you're called to breakfast. And you sit down, and ugh, you think. Oh god, another day. But somehow, it registers.
嗯，那个放在水果下面，或者别的什么东西，水煮蛋，或者视情况而定。我想这归根结底是因为我喜欢它看起来漂亮。我觉得这能让你振作起来，即使你只是匆匆路过，被叫去吃早餐。你坐下来，想：“呃，又是新的一天。”但不知怎么的，它留下了印象。
Or at least, it registers with me. If I have a nice breakfast, and I'm not feeling just great, it helps to improve my mood. So I think it's a nice thing to do.
至少，它在我这儿留下了印象。如果我吃了一顿不错的早餐，而且我感觉不怎么好，这有助于改善我的心情。所以我认为这是件好事。
And I don't like the plates just thrown on the table. I like them to look organized and neat and thoughtfully placed. So sometimes people help me, and they just scatter it on the table. Would you like some raspberries?
而且我不喜欢盘子被随意丢在桌子上。我喜欢它们看起来井井有条、摆放整齐且经过深思熟虑。所以有时人们帮我，他们只是把盘子撒在桌上。你想吃点树莓吗？
We ate in the day room, which was always full of stale smoke from the night before. Someone from the kitchen would come up with a contraption on wheels full of trays, each one with a name on it. We'd take our places. Everyone had a special table. One woman had her own, where no one else could sit. No one could touch her tray, either, or talk to her during meals.
我们在日间休息室吃东西，那里总是弥漫着前一晚留下的陈旧烟味。厨房里会有人推着装满托盘的架子走上来，每个托盘上都有名字。我们各就各位。每个人都有固定的桌子。有个女人有自己的桌子，别人不能坐。谁也不能碰她的托盘，也不能在吃饭时和她说话。
Our trays came laden with various pre-measured parcels, Melba toast in packets of four, plastic containers of raisins and peanut butter, all things that we had gone over with the nutritionist the day before. I remember sitting in her office in the afternoon. She'd take out a calculator and the next day's menu and say, "What do you want to eat tomorrow?" "I don't know. I don't want to eat tomorrow."
我们的托盘装满了各种预先称好的包裹，四片装的梅尔巴吐司，装有葡萄干和花生酱的塑料盒，这些都是我们前一天和营养师商量好的。我记得下午坐在她的办公室里。她拿出计算器和第二天的菜单说：“你明天想吃什么？”“我不知道。我明天不想吃东西。”
Every day, there was a schedule, mostly meals interspersed with activities like dance therapy and art therapy, with some snacks in between. At night, after dinner, we'd sit around in a circle next to the television, holding hands and listening to music. A few of us would cry. Some people would smoke cigarettes. And then we'd go to bed.
每天都有时间表，主要是穿插了舞蹈治疗、艺术治疗等活动的用餐时间，中间还有零食。晚上，晚饭后，我们坐在电视机旁的圆圈里，拉着手听音乐。我们中有几个人会哭。有些人会抽烟。然后我们就上床睡觉了。
It went on like that for a while, until one morning, the doctor said he'd put me on the tube if I didn't start eating. I remember leaving his office and turning down the hall and seeing some girls there, who were taking turns walking up and down, judging each other's thighs. Each one said hers were bigger, but none of them were. And it dawned on me then that if I kept going, I might never come back.
这种情况持续了一段时间，直到一天早上，医生说如果我不开始吃东西，就要插管喂食。我记得走出他的办公室，转过走廊，看到几个女孩在那里轮流走来走去，评判对方的大腿。每个人都说自己的大腿更粗，其实都没有。那时我突然意识到，如果我继续下去，我可能永远都回不来了。
And so at lunch that day, I asked the girl next to me if she'd dare me to finish what was on my plate. She did. And from that day on, I ate. And they finally let me out on April Fool's Day, 1988.
所以那天午饭时，我问旁边的女孩，她敢不敢打赌让我吃完盘子里的东西。她答应了。从那天起，我开始吃饭。他们最终在1988年的愚人节让我出院了。
I think I had some flowers in your room, where I'd put your favorite sheets on the bed. And you seemed pleased by that. But I very quickly realized how fragile you were. But the helpful thing was that while you were fragile, you also seemed so appreciative of my help.
我想我在你的房间里放了一些花，给你铺上了最喜欢的床单。你看起来很喜欢。但我很快意识到你当时有多脆弱。但有益的一面是，虽然你很脆弱，但也看起来很感激我的帮助。
And there were times when it was so overwhelming that you would just collapse in sobs on your bed. And I remember the nice thing was that I actually felt that I could be helpful to you. And so sometimes I'd just sit and talk to you.
有时情况太让人难以承受，你会直接在床上崩溃大哭。我记得好的一点是，我确实觉得我能帮到你。所以有时我会坐下来陪你说话。
And afterwards, you'd say, "Well, you know, I really appreciate your support." And so that made me feel much better because it was so different than it had been six months before, when it was impossible to reach you. Well anyway, that was a wonderful turning point.
事后，你会说：“嗯，你知道，我真的很感激你的支持。”这让我感觉好多了，因为这和六个月前你无法沟通的状态太不一样了。总之，那是一个美妙的转折点。
When I came home, I ate my breakfast somewhere else until eventually, it got easier, and I started to sit at the table across from my brother again. There were still a lot of plates. And we didn't talk about what had happened. In fact, we haven't really talked about it until now, 10 years later.
回到家后，我在别处吃早餐，直到后来情况好转，我又开始坐在桌边，和我哥哥面对面。盘子依然很多。我们没有谈论发生过的事。事实上，直到现在，10年后，我们才真正谈起它。
Oh, why didn't I keep some kind of journal about this? This was just astounding. Because after a while, your memory's so selective, you don't remember the worst things.
噢，为什么我没记点日记呢？这太令人震惊了。因为过了一段时间，你的记忆变得很有选择性，你记不住最糟糕的事情。
To tell you the truth, I'm pretty hard on my parents and the part they played in my illness. But looking back on those times, I also think about my mother and how she kept trying, no matter how often I retreated into my body and refused her help. She sat with me and waited until I was ready to face up to my feelings, I mean, any feelings.
说实话，我对我父母和他们在我的疾病中扮演的角色评价很严苛。但回过头看那段时光，我也想到我母亲，无论我多少次退缩回自己的身体并拒绝她的帮助，她都在坚持。她陪着我，等着我准备好去面对自己的感受——我是说，任何感受。
[MUSIC PLAYING - ANNIE CHENEY PLAYING  A SCHUMANN PIANO PIECE]
[音乐播放 - 安妮·切尼演奏舒曼钢琴曲]
I'll try it again. The same area where I made the mistakes before, I can't remember how to get out of the mistakes. I mean there's a certain chord, and then if I play that chord, then I can get out of the mistake I'm going to make. But I can never remember which chord it is.
我再试一遍。以前犯错的同一个地方，我记不得怎么克服那个错误了。我是说，有一个特定的和弦，如果我弹那个和弦，我就能走出错误。但我永远记不住是哪个和弦。
[MUSIC PLAYING - ANNIE CHENEY PLAYING  A SCHUMANN PIANO PIECE]
[音乐播放 - 安妮·切尼演奏舒曼钢琴曲]
I still don't know if I'm completely better. There are times even now when I prefer hard bones over softness and sorrow, when I don't want to know the truth. For instance, I never asked my brother if I could interview him for this story. I thought he might embarrass me or tell me something I didn't want to hear. It was my mother who told me later that he felt left out and that I should talk to him.
我仍然不知道自己是否完全好转了。即使是现在，有时我还是更喜欢坚硬的骨头而非柔软和悲伤，当我不愿面对真相时。例如，我从未问过我哥哥能否采访他做这个故事。我想他可能会让我难堪，或者告诉我我不想听的东西。是后来我母亲告诉我，他觉得被冷落了，我应该和他聊聊。
Yeah, I think that just played into a lot of the feelings I had at the time, when I was like, "Well, why haven't I been asked?" I'm not going to go over and ask you, "Why haven't you interviewed me?" Because I had assumed there was--
是啊，我想那确实影响了我当时的很多感受，我当时会想：“好吧，为什么没问我？”我不会主动去问你：“为什么没采访我？”因为我假设——
Well, why not?
嗯，为什么不问呢？
Well, because I don't feel it's my place to come and like, "Oh, can I please be interviewed?" Because I feel like if you have to ask, it would be very demeaning. It felt demeaning to me. And I feel like you should have, as a reporter, looked for all the sides of the story. You want some selective version of what happened. And you were afraid I was going to bring up something--
因为我觉得主动要求“噢，能采访我吗？”不是我的位置。这让我觉得很卑微。我当时觉得很卑微。我觉得作为记者，你应该寻找故事的所有侧面。你想要某种有选择性的事情版本。而且你害怕我会提到什么——
I have to admit, I did want my brother to come to me.
我必须承认，我确实希望我哥哥主动来找我。
You're not doing your job as a reporter.
你没尽到记者的职责。
In some ways, anorexia was about having other people come to me.
在某些方面，厌食症就是关于让别人主动来找我。
--avoiding the landmines and just sticking--
——避开地雷，只是坚持——
I wanted relationships on my terms. My father's like that, too. When I was still in the hospital, and I was starting to get better, I called him up and asked him if he'd take me to the movies. He said he'd take me if I gained half a pound. And so we didn't go.
我想要按自己的方式建立关系。我父亲也是这样。我还在医院里开始好转时，打电话问他能否带我去看电影。他说如果我增重半磅他就带我去。结果我们就没去。
We were trying to coerce each other and defy each other. We were locked in some kind of a grip of anger and defiance. It was as if one of the Greek gods had decided to punish us for hubris.
我们试图互相强迫、互相抗衡。我们被困在一种愤怒和反抗的枷锁中。就好像希腊众神决定因为我们的傲慢而惩罚我们。
Where'd that come from?
那从哪儿来的？
The hubris came from our presumably thinking we were doing all the right things, going to a private school, being able to afford what we were able to afford, and buying things and having a materially successful life and whatever set of-- having some kind of reverence for each other. What did I tell you? Sometimes I think the only thing that makes a difference is the passage of time.
傲慢来自于我们想当然地认为自己在做所有正确的事，上私立学校，负担得起我们能负担得起的，买东西，过着物质上成功的生活，还有任何一套——对彼此有某种敬畏。我和你说过什么？有时我觉得唯一能改变什么的就是时间的推移。
You make all kinds of mistakes. But time passes, and then somehow, things get cured a little bit. And life goes on in a new way. Yup. Well, I'll take you to the movies sometime.
你会犯各种错误。但时间过去了，然后不知怎么的，事情就得到了一点治愈。生活以新的方式继续。是啊。好吧，有空带你去看电影。
OK.
好的。
Tell me what you had for breakfast.
告诉我你早餐吃了什么。
I had anxiety laden with a very thin coating of agitation. And it was coupled with a cup of very lukewarm pseudo-comfort, in the form of an anti-depressant.
我吃下了焦虑，上面薄薄地涂了一层烦躁。还配了一杯非常温热的伪慰藉，以抗抑郁药的形式。
After I finished interviewing my parents, I went back to talk to Vivian again. And I asked her how she felt, and if she thought she'd ever get better. She said she realized, finally, what she'd done, and how her body would never be the same again.
采访完我父母后，我又去和维维安谈了谈。我问她感觉如何，是否认为自己还会好转。她说她终于意识到自己做了什么，以及她的身体将永远不会再一样了。
I realized I've lost all my back teeth due to my illness. I'm getting old. I've hurt myself. I'm falling apart. And I started crying.
我意识到因为疾病我掉了所有的后牙。我老了。我伤害了自己。我正在崩溃。然后我就哭了。
Ten seconds later, she told me this.
10秒后，她告诉我这个。
I desperately want to lose weight. I am desperate to lose weight.
我极度想瘦。我极度渴望瘦。
I could tell you she's going to find a way out, and I could tell you she's never going to change, and both things would be true. And she'd tell you the same thing.
我可以告诉你她会找到出路，我也可以告诉你她永远不会改变，这两者都是真的。她也会告诉你同样的话。
As for me, I've started going out with my microphone looking for stories that I want to tell. I talked to one woman named Louise who started making hats out of carpet scraps when she was diagnosed with skin cancer.
至于我，我已经开始拿着麦克风去寻找我想讲述的故事。我采访了一位名叫露易丝的女性，她在确诊皮肤癌后开始用碎地毯做帽子。
And they really do a good job. They healed my cancer.
它们真的做得很好。它们治愈了我的癌症。
She told me she's really excited about the rest of her life because she finally feels like she can be herself.
她告诉我她对余生感到非常兴奋，因为她终于觉得自己可以做自己了。
I'm past 90 now.
我现在已经过了90岁了。
You are?
你是吗？
Mm-hmm. And someday, I'll die, whether I want to or not.
嗯。总有一天，我会死，不管我愿不愿意。
She played the piano for me, a song she learned when she was 12 and still remembers.
她为我弹奏了钢琴，那是她12岁时学会并至今记得的一首歌。
Here's the Chopin prelude.
这是肖邦前奏曲。
[MUSIC PLAYING - A CHOPIN PRELUDE  PLAYED BY LOUISE]
[音乐播放 - 露易丝演奏肖邦前奏曲]
I went out and got the sheet music for the Schumann piece.
我出去买了舒曼那首曲子的乐谱。
[MUSIC PLAYING - ANNIE CHENEY PLAYING  A SCHUMANN PIANO PIECE]
[音乐播放 - 安妮·切尼演奏舒曼钢琴曲]
I've even played it and gotten past that chord.
我甚至弹奏并克服了那个和弦。
[MUSIC PLAYING - ANNIE CHENEY PLAYING  A SCHUMANN PIANO PIECE]
[音乐播放 - 安妮·切尼演奏舒曼钢琴曲]
Annie Cheney's story was produced by Jay Allison as part of his Life Stories series, with help from Tina Egloff and funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting. Coming up, Lord of the Flies enacted with tacos, baby carrots, and a gallon of 1% milk. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
安妮·切尼的故事由杰·艾利森作为其《人生故事》系列的一部分制作，由蒂娜·埃格洛夫协助，并获得公共广播公司资助。接下来，用塔可、小胡萝卜和一加仑1%牛奶演绎的《苍蝇王》。国际公共广播电台的节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of stories on that theme. Today's program, You Gonna Eat That? Three stories of three families at three meals. Act One was about breakfast. We have arrived at Act Two, Lunch. In this act, we hear things strictly from the parent's point of view. We have this story from Ian Frazier, "Laws Concerning Food and Drink; Household Principles; Lamentations of the Father."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来有关该主题的各种故事。今天的节目主题是《你打算吃那个吗？》。三个家庭三餐的三个故事。第一幕是关于早餐。我们现在进入第二幕，午餐。在这一幕中，我们严格从家长的角度来听。我们听听伊恩·弗雷泽的故事，“关于饮食的律法；家庭原则；父亲的哀歌”。
Of the beasts of the field and of the fishes of the sea and of all foods that are acceptable in my sight, you may eat, but not in the living room. Of the hoofed animals, broiled and ground into burgers, you may eat, but not in the living room. Of the cloven-hoofed animal, plain or with cheese, you may eat, but not in the living room.
在田野的百兽、海洋的游鱼以及我眼目所及一切可接受的食物中，你们可以吃，但不可在客厅吃。对于蹄类动物，烤制并剁碎成汉堡的，你们可以吃，但不可在客厅吃。对于偶蹄动物，纯味的或加奶酪的，你们可以吃，但不可在客厅吃。
Of the cereal grains, of the corn and of the wheat and of the oats, and of all the cereals that are of bright color and unknown provenance, you may eat, but not in the living room. Of the quiescently frozen dessert, and of all frozen after-meal treats, you make eat, but absolutely not in the living room. Of the juices and other beverages, yes, even of those in sippy cups, you may drink, but not in the living room. Neither may you carry such therein.
对于谷物，对于玉米、小麦和燕麦，以及所有颜色鲜艳、来源不明的谷物，你们可以吃，但不可在客厅吃。对于冷冻甜点，以及所有饭后冷冻零食，你们可以吃，但绝对不可在客厅吃。对于果汁和其他饮料，是的，即使是吸管杯里的，你们也可以喝，但不可在客厅喝。也不得将这些带入客厅。
Indeed, when you reach the place where the living room carpet begins, of any food or beverage, there you may not eat. Neither may you drink. But if you are sick and are lying down and watching something, then you may eat in the living room.
事实上，当你到达客厅地毯开始的地方，对于任何食物或饮料，都不得在那里吃。也不得喝。但如果你病了，正躺着看什么东西，那么你可以在客厅吃。
And if you are seated in your high chair, or in a chair such as a greater person might use, keep your legs and feet below you, as they were. Neither raise up your knees, nor place your feet upon the table, for that is an abomination to me. Yes, even when you have an interesting bandage to show, your feet upon the table are an abomination, and worthy of rebuke.
如果你坐在高脚椅里，或大人们可能使用的那种椅子里，保持双腿和双脚在下面，就像原来的那样。既不要抬起膝盖，也不要将脚放在桌子上，因为那对我来说是可憎的。是的，即使当你有一个有趣的绷带要展示，把脚放在桌上也是可憎的，值得责备。
Drink your milk as it is given to you. Neither use on it any utensils, nor fork, nor knife, nor spoon, for that is not what they are for. If you will dip your blocks in the milk and lick it off, you will be sent away. When you have drunk, let the empty cup then remain upon the table and do not by bite it upon its edge and by your teeth, hold it to your face in order to make noises in it, sounding like a duck, for you will be sent away.
按照给你的样子喝牛奶。不要在上面使用任何器具，不要用叉子、刀子或勺子，因为它们不是为了这个用的。如果你要把积木浸在牛奶里再舔掉，你就会被赶走。喝完后，空杯子就留在桌上，不要用牙齿咬它的边缘，并用牙齿把它贴在脸上发出那种声音，听起来像鸭子，因为你会被赶走。
When you chew your food, keep your mouth closed until you have swallowed and do not open it to show your brother or your sister what is within. I say to you, do not so, even if your brother or your sister has done the same to you.
咀嚼食物时，保持嘴巴闭合直到吞下，不要张开嘴向兄弟或姐妹展示里面的东西。我对你说，不可这样做，即使你的兄弟或姐妹对你也这样做。
Eat your food only. Do not eat that which is not food. Neither seize the table between your jaws, nor use the raiment or the table to wipe your lips. I say again to you, do not touch it, but leave it as it is.
只吃你的食物。不要吃那些不是食物的东西。既不要用牙齿紧咬桌子，也不要用衣服或桌布擦嘴。我再说一遍，不要碰它，让它保持原样。
And though your stick of carrot does indeed resemble a marker, draw not with it upon the table, even in pretend, for we do not do that, that is why. And though the pieces of broccoli are very like small trees, do not stand them upright to make a forest, because we do not do that, that is why. Sit just as I have told you and do not lean to one side or the other, nor slide down until you are nearly slid away. Heed me, for if you sit like that, your hair will go into the syrup. And now behold, even as I have said, it has come to pass.
虽然你的胡萝卜条确实像记号笔，但不要在桌子上画，即使是假装，因为我们不那样做，这就是原因。虽然西兰花碎片很像小树，但不要把它们竖起来做成森林，因为我们不那样做，这就是原因。就像我告诉你那样坐好，不要向一侧或另一侧倾斜，也不要滑下去直到快溜走。听我说，如果你那样坐，你的头发会掉进糖浆里。现在看，正如我所说的，它发生了。
For we judge between the plate that is unclean and the plate that is clean, saying first, if the plate is clean, than you shall have dessert. But of the unclean plate, the laws are these. If you have eaten most of your meat and two bites of your peas, with each bite consisting of not less than three peas each, or in total, six peas, eaten where I can see, and you have also eaten enough of your potatoes to fill two forks, both forkfuls eaten where I can see, then you shall have dessert.
因为我们区分不干净的盘子和干净的盘子，首先说，如果盘子是干净的，那你就可以吃甜点。但关于不干净的盘子，律法是这样的：如果你已经吃完大部分肉和两口豌豆，每一口不少于三颗豌豆，或者总共六颗豌豆，在我能看到的地方吃完，并且你也吃够了足以装满两叉子的土豆，两叉子都在我能看到的地方吃完，那么你就可以吃甜点。
But if you eat a lesser number of peas and yet you eat the potatoes, still, you shall not have dessert. And if you eat the peas, yet leave the potatoes uneaten, you shall not have dessert, no, not even a small portion thereof. And if you try to deceive by moving the potatoes or peas around with a fork, that it may appear you have eaten what you have not, you will fall into iniquity. And I will know. And you shall have no dessert.
但如果你吃的豌豆数量较少，尽管你吃了土豆，你还是不能吃甜点。如果你吃了豌豆，却没吃土豆，你不能吃甜点，不，哪怕是一小部分也不行。如果你试图通过用叉子拨弄土豆或豌豆来欺骗，让人觉得你吃了其实没吃的东西，你就会陷入不义。我会知道的。你就没有甜点可吃。
Do not scream, for it is as if you scream all the time. If you are given a plate on which two foods you do not wish to touch each other are touching each other, your voice rises up even to the ceiling, while you point to the offense with the finger of your right hand. But I say to you, scream not. Only remonstrate gently with the server that the server may correct the fault.
不要尖叫，因为你好像一直在尖叫。如果你得到的盘子里有两样你不希望碰在一起的食物碰在一起了，你的声音会升到天花板，同时用右手手指指向冒犯之处。但我对你说，不要尖叫。只要温和地对服务员提出，让服务员纠正错误即可。
Likewise, if you receive a portion of fish from which every piece of herbal seasoning has not been scraped off, and the herbal seasoning is loathsome to you and steeped in vileness, again I say, refrain from screaming. Though the vileness overwhelm you and cause you a faint unto death, make not that sound from within your throat. Neither cover your face nor press your fingers to your nose, for even now, I have made the fish as it should be. Behold, I eat of it myself, yet do not die.
同样，如果你收到的一份鱼上没有刮掉所有的草本调味料，而你觉得那种调味料令人厌恶、浸透着卑劣，我再说一遍，不要尖叫。虽然这种卑劣让你难以承受，甚至昏死过去，但不要从喉咙里发出那种声音。既不要遮住脸也不要用手指按鼻子，因为即使现在，我也已经把鱼弄成了它该有的样子。看，我自己都在吃，却没死。
Cast your countenance upward to the light and lift your eyes to the hills, that I may more easily wash you off. For the stains are upon you, even to the very back of your head there is rice thereon. And in your breast pocket of your garment, and upon the tie of your shoe, rice and other fragments are distributed in a manner wonderful to see. Only hold yourself still, hold still, I say.
将你的脸转向光，抬起眼睛望向山丘，好让我更容易把你洗干净。因为污渍都在你身上，甚至到你后脑勺都有米粒。在你衣服的胸袋里，在你鞋带上，米粒和其他碎片分布的方式令人惊叹。只要保持安静，静止不动，我说。
Give each finger in its turn for my examination thereof, and also each thumb. Lo, how iniquitous they appear. What I do is as it must be, and you shall not go hence until I have done.
把每一根手指依次拿来让我检查，还有每一个大拇指。瞧，它们看起来多么邪恶。我做的事是必须做的，你哪里也不能去，直到我做完。
Bite not, lest you be cast into quiet time. Neither drink of your own bath water, nor of bath water of any kind, nor rub your feet on bread, even if it be in the package, nor rub yourself against cars, nor against any building, nor eat sand. Leave the cat alone, for what has the cat done that you should so afflict it with tape? And hum not that humming in your nose as I read, nor stand between the light and the book. Indeed, you will drive me to madness. Nor forget what I said about the tape.
不要咬人，否则你会被关禁闭。不要喝自己的洗澡水，也不要喝任何洗澡水，不要在面包上擦脚，即使它在包装里，也不要对着汽车、建筑物摩擦自己，不要吃沙子。别理那只猫，那猫做了什么让你非要用胶带折磨它？我读书时，不要在鼻子里哼那种声音，不要站在光和书之间。真的，你会把我逼疯。也不要忘了我关于胶带说的话。
O my children, you are disobedient. For when I tell you what you must do, you argue and dispute hotly, even to the littlest detail. And when I do not accede, you cry out and hit and kick. Yes, and even sometimes do you spit and shout "stupid-head" and other blasphemies, and hit and kick the wall in the molding thereof when you are sent to the corner.
噢我的孩子们，你们真不听话。因为当我告诉你们必须做什么时，你们争辩、激烈反驳，甚至到最小的细节。当我不同意时，你们大叫、打人、踢人。是的，甚至有时还会吐口水、大喊“笨蛋”之类的亵渎话语，被关进角落时还会踢墙壁和踢脚线。
And though the law teaches that no one shall be sent to the corner for more minutes than he has years of age, yet I would leave you there all day, so mighty am I in anger. But upon being sent to the corner, you ask straight away, "Can I come out?" And I reply, "No, you may not come out." And again you ask, and again I give the same reply. But when you ask again a third time, then you may come out.
虽然法律规定被关在角落的时间不能超过岁数，但我真想把你们关在那里一整天，因为我愤怒得厉害。但被关到角落后，你们马上问：“我能出来吗？”我回答：“不，你不能出来。”你们又问，我再次给予同样的回答。但当你们第三次问时，你们才可以出来。
Hear me, O my children, for the bills, they kill me. I pay and pay again, even to the 12th time in a year, and yet again, they mount higher than before. For our health, that we may be covered, I give 620 talents 12 times in a year, but even this covers not the 1,500 deductible for each member of the family within a calendar year. And yet for ordinary visits, we still are not covered, nor for many medicines, nor for the teeth within our mouths. Guess not at what rage is in my mind, for surely, you cannot know.
听我说，噢我的孩子们，因为那些账单简直要了我的命。我支付又支付，一年里甚至支付了12次，然而它们比以前更高。为了我们的健康，为了我们有保障，我一年里付了12次620塔兰特，但即使这样也没覆盖每个家庭成员每年1500元的免赔额。对于普通就诊我们仍没保障，也没有药物，更没有嘴里的牙齿。别猜我心里有多愤怒，因为你们肯定不知道。
For I will come to you at the first of the month and at the 15th of the month with the bills and a great whining, and moan. And when the month of taxes comes, I will decry the wrongs and unfairness of it and mourn with wine and ashtrays and rend my receipts. And you shall remember that I am that I am, before, after, and until you are 21. Hear me, then, and avoid me in my wrath, O children of me.
因为我会在月初和月中带着账单、巨大的抱怨和呻吟来找你们。当纳税月份到来时，我会谴责其中的不公和不合理，用酒和烟灰缸哀悼，撕碎我的收据。你们要记住我就是我，在你们21岁之前，之前和之后都是如此。听我说，在我的愤怒中避开我，我的孩子们。
Ian Frazier is a humor writer, essayist, and nonfiction writer. His collection of humor pieces is called Coyote v. Acme, from Farrar, Strauss, & Giroux. This story was read for us by Peter Sagal, a new father himself, and host of NPR's news quiz program, Wait, Wait, Don't Tell Me.
伊恩·弗雷泽是位幽默作家、散文家和非虚构作家。他的幽默作品集叫《郊狼对艾克米》，由法拉-施特劳斯-吉鲁出版社出版。这个故事由彼得·萨格尔为我们朗读，他自己也是一位新晋父亲，还是 NPR 新闻问答节目《等等，别告诉我》的主持人。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "MEAT MAN" BY JERRY LEE LEWIS]
[音乐播放 - 杰瑞·李·刘易斯的《Meat Man》]
Act Three, Dinner. Well, all this hour, we've been hearing stories of parents and children. Now, a story of when the children have to become the parents, and what happens. When Dave Eggers's parents died, he was 21. His sister, Beth, was 23. And his brother, Toph, was 8. Dave took custody of Toph, and the two of them moved from Illinois to Berkeley. His sister lived nearby. This story takes place about a year into his sudden and unexpected turn at parenthood, parenting his brother.
第三幕，晚餐。嗯，这一小时里我们一直在听父母和孩子的故事。现在讲个当孩子不得不成为父母时的故事，以及发生了什么。当戴夫·埃格斯的父母去世时，他21岁。他姐姐贝丝23岁。他弟弟托普8岁。戴夫获得了托普的监护权，他们俩从伊利诺伊州搬到了伯克利。他姐姐住在附近。这个故事发生在他在突然且意外地承担起抚养弟弟的职责大约一年后。
Dinner is really the only meal we treat in any remotely formal way. Our days work like this-- first, Toph wakes up at 4:00, 4:30 in the morning, so as to allow 10 minutes to shower, 10 minutes to dress, half an hour to make and eat breakfast, finish his homework, and pack his launch, and at least three and a half hours for cartoons.
晚餐确实是我们唯一以某种正式方式对待的一餐。我们的一天是这样度过的——首先，托普在清晨4点、4点半起床，这样能预留10分钟洗澡、10分钟穿衣、半小时做早餐并吃完、完成作业、打包午餐，以及至少三个半小时看动画片。
At 8:45, he wakes me up. At 8:50, he wakes me up again. At 8:55, he wakes me up one more time. And, while yelling at him because he's late, I drive him to school.
8点45分，他叫醒我。8点50分，他又叫醒我。8点55分，他又叫醒我一次。在我因为他迟到而对他大吼大叫时，我开车送他去学校。
I park our little red car next to the school on the east side, where I've been told in four separate flyers and one personal note, is not to used for the loading or unloading of children. Then I grab a piece of paper from his backpack and compose a note. "Dear Mrs. Richardson, I am sorry Toph is late this morning. I could make up something about an appointment or a sickness, but the fact is that we woke up late. Sincerely, Dave Eggers." He reads the note. "We woke up late?" I give him the look. "Fine," he says.
我把我们那辆红色小车停在学校东侧，那里我被四份传单和一张便条告知，严禁用于接送孩子。然后我从他书包里拿出一张纸写道：“亲爱的理查德森夫人，我很抱歉托普今天早上迟到了。我可以编造关于预约或生病的借口，但事实是我们起晚了。戴夫·埃格斯致。”他读了便条。“我们起晚了？”我瞪了他一眼。“好吧，”他说。
Then, depending on whether or not we like each other that day, I try to do the across the bucket seats hug. I reach over, pull him near, and say, "Your hat smells like urine," because it does. "No, it doesn't," he says. It does.
然后，取决于那天我们是否互相喜欢，我试着做个跨越座椅的拥抱。我探过身，把他拉近说：“你的帽子有尿味，”因为确实有。“不，没有，”他说。确实有。
"Smell it," I say. "I'm not going to smell it," he says. "You should wash it," I say. "It doesn't smell," he says. "Whatever," I say. "Whatever," he mimics. "That's good," I say. "I like that." Then I go to work.
“闻闻看，”我说。“我才不闻，”他说。“你应该洗洗它，”我说。“它没味儿，”他说。“随你便，”我说。“随你便，”他模仿道。“很好，”我说。“我喜欢这样。”然后我去上班。
After school, my sister, Beth, picks him up, and she stays at our house until I get home, at which point, Beth and I try to fight about something extremely important and lasting. "Can you not make such a mess when you come over here?" "Mess? Look at this place? Mess?" And once we have done this, she leaves. Then Toph and I cook.
放学后，我姐姐贝丝接他，并在我们家待到我回家，那时，贝丝和我试着为某件极其重要且持久的事情争吵。“你过来能不能别把这儿搞得这么乱？”“乱？看看这地方？乱？”一旦我们吵完了，她就走了。然后托普和我做饭。
The menu from which we choose consists of seven items and seven items only, which we rotate with mathematical precision. Here are the highlights. One, stir-fried beef. Sirloin strips, sliced and sauteed in Kikkoman brand soy sauce, cooked until black, served with tortillas, and eaten by hand. On the side, we have potatoes, served in the French manner, and sliced oranges and apples, in a bowl.
我们选择的菜单包括七种菜品，且只有七种，我们以精确的数学规律轮换。亮点如下。第一，炒牛肉。沙朗牛排条，在龟甲万品牌酱油中炒制，煮到黑色，配上玉米饼，用手吃。配菜是法式土豆，还有碗里切好的橙子和苹果。
Two, tacos en fuego. Ground beef sauteed in Prego spaghetti sauce, traditional style, served with tortillas and without additional embellishment. Pillsbury crescent rolls and iceberg salad served on the side. Three, pizza pronto, served with pepperoni, courtesy of Pizza Hut. Served with a small salad.
第二，火焰塔可。牛肉末在 Prego 意大利面酱中炒熟，传统风格，配上玉米饼，无需额外装饰。配菜是皮尔斯伯里新月卷和冰山生菜沙拉。第三，Pizza Pronto，配上意大利辣香肠，由必胜客提供。配上一份小沙拉。
Four, grilled cheese quesadilla dinner. Grilled cheese served with one slice of Kraft American cheese set in the middle of two pieces of seeded Jewish rye, toasted in pan and cut diagonally. Quesadillas prepared in skillet with tortillas and American cheese.
第四，烤奶酪油炸玉米饼晚餐。烤奶酪配上一片放在两片带籽犹太黑麦面包中间的卡夫美国奶酪，在平底锅里烤制并对角切开。油炸玉米饼在煎锅里用玉米饼和美国奶酪制成。
Note-- no spices are available. There is no salt, no pepper, no parsley, sage, rosemary, or thyme. No vegetables are available, except baby carrots, pre-cut celery, cucumbers, green beans, and iceberg lettuce, all served raw and only raw. Pasta is not available because it smells funny and is too slithery.
注意——没有调料。没有盐，没有胡椒，没有欧芹、鼠尾草、迷迭香或百里香。没有蔬菜，除了小胡萝卜、预切芹菜、黄瓜、青豆和冰山生菜，全部生食且只许生食。不提供意大利面，因为闻起来怪怪的且太滑了。
All meals are served with a tall glass of 1% milk with the gallon jug resting on the floor next to the table for convenient refills. Alternative beverages are not available. Anything not on the menu is not available. Any complaints will be handled quickly and with severity.
所有餐点都配上一大杯1%牛奶，牛奶壶放在桌旁地上方便续杯。不提供其他饮料。菜单上没有的都不提供。任何抱怨都会被迅速且严厉地处理。
We cook about four times a week. "Hey, I need your help," I say when I need his help cooking. "OK," he says, and then he helps out with the cooking.
我们大约一周做四次饭。“嘿，我需要你帮忙，”我需要他帮忙做饭时会这么说。“好的，”他说，然后他就帮忙一起做。
Sometimes we sing while we're cooking. We sing regular words, words about pouring the milk or getting the spaghetti sauce or microwaving the tortillas, but we sing them in opera style. We can sing lots of different ways, but the opera style is pretty impressive. People have said so. Sometimes while cooking, we have sword fights with wooden spoons, or with the dowels that used to hold up the drapes.
有时我们做饭时会唱歌。我们唱正常的歌词，关于倒牛奶、拿意大利面酱或用微波炉加热玉米饼的歌词，但我们以歌剧风格唱。我们可以用很多不同的方式唱，但歌剧风格相当令人印象深刻。人们都这么说。有时做饭时，我们会用木勺或者曾经支撑窗帘的木杆进行击剑决斗。
It's an unsaid mission of mine, the source of which is sometimes clear and sometimes not, to keep things moving, to entertain the boy, to keep him on his toes. For a while, we would chase each other around the house, from bathroom to kitchen to bathroom, mouths full of water, threatening to spit. Of course, neither of us would have ever thought of actually spitting a mouthful of water at the other inside the house. Until one night, when I had him cornered in the kitchen, I just went ahead and did it. Things have been devolving ever since. I've stuck a half cantaloupe into his face. I've rubbed a handful of banana into his chest, poured a glassful of apple juice on his head. It's all part of an effort, I'm guessing, to let him know, if it weren't already pretty obvious, that we're not in Kansas anymore, or Illinois.
我的一个未言明的使命，来源有时清晰有时不然，就是让事情继续运转，逗男孩开心，让他保持警觉。有段时间，我们会满屋子追逐，从浴室到厨房再到浴室，嘴里含着水，威胁要吐出来。当然，我们俩谁也不会真的想在屋子里互相喷水。直到一个晚上，当我在厨房把他逼到角落时，我直接就做了。从那以后情况就开始恶化了。我把半个哈密瓜贴在他脸上。我把一把香蕉泥擦在他胸口，往他头上倒了一杯苹果汁。我猜，这都是为了让他知道——如果还不明显的话——我们已经不在堪萨斯州或伊利诺伊州了。
There's a voice inside me, a very excited, chirpy voice, that urges me to keep things merry, madcap even, the mood buoyant. Because Beth is always pulling out old photo albums, crying, and asking Toph how he feels, I feel like I have to overcompensate, keep us occupied. I'm making our lives a music video, a game show on Nickelodeon, with quick cuts, crazy camera angles, lots of fun, fun, fun. It's a campaign of distraction and disinformation, leaflets dropped behind enemy lines, flares and fireworks, funny dances, shell games, magic tricks. What's that? Lookie there. Where'd it go?
我心里有个声音，非常兴奋、欢快的声音，敦促我保持愉快，甚至疯狂，心情开朗。因为贝丝总是拿出旧相册，哭着问托普感觉如何，我觉得我必须过度补偿，保持我们的忙碌。我把我们的生活做成了一部音乐录影带，一个尼克儿童频道的游戏节目，有快速剪辑，疯狂的摄像角度，很多很多的乐趣。这是一场分心和虚假信息的战役，在敌后投下传单，照明弹和烟花，滑稽的舞蹈，障眼法，魔术。那是什么？看那儿。哪儿去了？
In the kitchen, when the inspiration strikes, I take out the family's 17-inch turkey knife, plant my legs square to him, squat a little, and hold the knife over my head samurai style. "Hiiiii!" I yell. "Don't," Toph says, backing away. "Huaa!" I yell, stepping toward him, because threatening children with 17-inch knives is funny. "Not funny," he says, halfway up the stairs. I put the knife away.
在厨房里，当灵感袭来，我会拿出家里那把17英寸的火鸡刀，双腿与他平行站立，微蹲，把刀举过头顶，忍者风格。“嘿！”我大喊。“别这样，”托普往后退着说。“哈！”我大喊，朝他走去，因为威胁孩子拿17英寸的刀很有趣。“不好笑，”他说，走到一半楼梯。我把刀收起来。
"Dad used to do that all the time," I say. "Out of the blue, he'd get this look on his face, this bug-eyed sort of look, and act like you he was going to split our heads open with the knife." "Sounds funny," says Toph. "Yeah," I say. "It was real funny."
“爸爸以前常这么做，”我说。“突然之间，他脸上会出现那种表情，那种眼珠突出的表情，装作要用刀劈开我们的脑袋。”“听起来很有趣，”托普说。“是啊，”我说。“那真是太有趣了。”
Sometimes while we cook, he tells me about things that happened at school. "What happened today?" I ask. He gives me the full rundown, who's a dork and who's OK, what everyone wrote their papers on, the whole thing. One time, he said this. "Today, Carl told me that he hopes you and Beth are in a plane, and that the plane crashes, and that you both die, just like Mom and Dad." "They didn't die in a plane crash," I say. "I told him that," he says.
有时我们做饭时，他会告诉我学校发生的事。“今天发生了什么？”我问。他会完整地讲给我听，谁是书呆子，谁还可以，每个人写的是什么论文，全套内容。有一次，他说了这个：“今天，卡尔告诉我，他希望你和贝丝在飞机上，然后飞机坠毁，你们俩都死了，就像妈妈和爸爸那样。”“他们不是死于空难，”我说。“我告诉过他了，”他说。
Sometimes I call the parents of Toph's classmates. "Yeah, that's what he said," I say. "It's hard enough, you know," I say, pouring it on. "No, he's OK. He's fine. I just don't know why Carl would say that. I mean, why do you suppose your son wants me and Beth to die in a plane crash? I just couldn't help wondering," I say. "No, no, he's fine. Don't worry about us. You should worry about young Carl there. I just wanted to let you know," I say. They'll let anyone be parents.
有时我给托普同学的家长打电话。“是啊，他就是这么说的，”我说。“你知道，这已经够难了，”我说，极力渲染。“不，他没问题。他很好。我只是不知道卡尔为什么会那么说。我是说，你认为为什么你的儿子希望我和贝丝死在空难中？我禁不住想知道，”我说。“不，不，他没问题。别担心我们。你应该担心年轻的卡尔。我只是想让你知道，”我说。他们真是什么人都能当家长。
During dinner, when there's basketball on, we watch the Bulls on cable. Otherwise, between bites, we play gin or crazy eights. If the dining room table is in ping pong mode, we eat on the coffee table. If the coffee table is in homework mode, we eat on the family room floor. If the family room floor is covered with plates from the night before, we eat in Toph's room on the carpet, watching his portable TV, which sits next to his bed. I know, I know.
晚餐时，如果有篮球比赛，我们就在有线电视上看公牛队的比赛。否则，在吃东西间隙，我们玩金罗美扑克或疯狂8点。如果餐桌在乒乓球模式，我们就用咖啡桌吃。如果咖啡桌在家庭作业模式，我们就用家庭室地板吃。如果家庭室地板铺满了前一晚的盘子，我们就用他的随身电视机在他卧室地毯上吃，电视就放在他床边。我知道，我知道。
The kitchen table, which is usually clean and has chairs around, and has room for plates and glasses and silverware, is out of the question. I mean, where's the fun in that? And where's the challenge?
那张通常干净、四周有椅子、放得下盘子、杯子和餐具的餐桌，根本不用想。我是说，那有什么乐趣？挑战又在哪？
After dinner, we play games for our own amusement and the edification of the neighbors. One game involves the cracking of the leather belt to simulate some well-deserved corporal punishment. Most involve Toph pretending that he's a kid, while I pretend I'm a parent.
晚餐后，我们为了自娱自乐和教育邻居而玩游戏。其中一个游戏包括挥舞皮带，模拟某种当之无愧的体罚。大多数游戏里，托普假装他是孩子，而我假装我是家长。
"Dad, can I drive the car?" he asks as I sit reading the paper. "No, son, you can't," I say, without looking up. "But why?" "Because I said so." "But Dad." "I said no." "I hate you I hate you, I hate you, I hate you," he shrieks. Then he runs to his room and slams the door.
“爸爸，我可以开车吗？”当我读报纸时他问。“不，儿子，你不能，”我没抬头说。“但为什么？”“因为我说了算。”“但爸爸。”“我说不行。”“我恨你，我恨你，我恨你，我恨你，”他尖叫道。然后他跑进卧室，“砰”地关上门。
After a second, he opens the door. "Was that good?" He asks. "Yeah," I say. "That was pretty good."
片刻后，他打开门。“刚才好吗？”他问。“挺好，”我说。“相当好。”
Dave Eggers edits the journal Timothy McSweeney's Quarterly Concern and is finishing a book about raising Toph, from which this story was taken. Toph is now in high school, doing just fine.
戴夫·埃格斯编辑了《蒂莫西·麦克斯威尼季度期刊》，并正在完成一本关于抚养托普的书，这个故事就取自该书。托普现在上了高中，表现很好。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder, contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from [? Emmie Takehara, ?] Todd Bachmann, and Sylvia Lemus. Music help today from John Connors.
嗯，我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克和我本人，以及阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德共同制作，特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。制作协助来自埃米·竹原、托德·巴克曼和西尔维娅·莱姆斯。音乐支持来自约翰·康纳斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this program or any of our programs, they make perfect Christmas presents. Call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] Or you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买本节目或我们任何节目的磁带，它们是完美的圣诞礼物。请致电我们芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，312-832-3380。312-832-3380。我们的电子邮箱是 [email protected] 你也可以在我们的网站 www.thislife.org 免费收听我们的大部分节目。感谢运营网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who warns you, if you do not pledge to your public radio station--
WBEZ 的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他警告说，如果你不向公共广播电台捐款——
You will fall into iniquity, and I will know. And you shall have no dessert.
你就会陷入不义，我会知道的。你就没有甜点可吃。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
And now behold, even as I have said, it has come to pass.
现在看，正如我所说的，它发生了。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。